okay I can do this I got here I'm sick
I'm still here oh my god my voice I
sound like I sound like Ivana Chubbuck
nice slow smoking voice okay rise and
shine it's in spresso time
good morning belief nation my name is
Lily and my one word is extraordinary I
believe that every single human being is
capable of extraordinary things when
they embrace who they truly are so let's
start your day off right together go
grab yourself a cup of coffee and sip on
today's message own your life over to
you Chris Gardner as jarring and strange
as change can be there were times when
it was hard to imagine that my life
would be what it is today
especially the time when my son and I
were living in that bathroom maybe
remember that scene in the movie there
was a highly polished sheet metal piece
over a sink it wasn't a mirror but it
served as a mirror and I had to wash
myself in that baby every day watch my
baby in this sink and had to ask myself
some very predictable questions what
happened why did this happen why did
that happen but the most difficult
question I had to get through was how
did I get here and the answer was even
more brutal the answer was I drove here
I had something to do with it
you can't change something until you own
it so if you're 50 plus and you're
sitting out there and pointing fingers
at other people you can do that for a
long time but it's hard to look in the
mirror and say how did I get here and
have the answer be I drove here I had
something to do with it it's
uncomfortable to admit that well I made
some bad decisions I made some
investments
I made I had something to do with it
well that man sold me that house with no
money down I should have told him what
he could do at that house huh when I
signed that adjustable rate mortgage we
all know these things only adjust
upwards no one's ever gonna call you and
say guess what you go pay less for your
money your house next year angle happen
so the idea of I drove here is
empowering because the other side of it
is if I drove here that means I can
drive out of here I have to own it and
that bathroom I finally had to
understand what my mama used to say to
me where she would say boy to Calvary is
not coming
ain't no backup I was 28 years old when
that part of my life happened change was
coming fast and you know what changes
everywhere all the time social change
technical logical change and the most
potent of all personal change the most
urgent question today is not so much as
what are my values and who are we the
urgent question on these times of
constant changes how exactly are you
going to navigate these new realities
put another way what are you going to do
I love this message I think it's so
important to take ownership of your life
and take responsibility for everything
good and bad and I know sometimes it's
so hard to actually do that because bad
things do happen to good people but
blaming others and blaming the situation
blaming on government regulations is not
going to do you any good it's actually
detrimental to your own well-being if
you take responsibility for you live
you'll see how you can actually open up
all sorts of opportunities for yourself
and it's actually very very empowering
so when I was 18 years old I wasn't a
really crappy relationship I was in a
relationship with someone who constantly
cheated on me all the time multiple
times with multiple people and I knew
about it and I remember receiving a
phone call from one of my really close
friends telling me that he did it again
he cheated on me and she saw it and I
remember sitting at the edge of my bed
freaking out panicking is like I cannot
believe this has happened to me again I
cannot believe what a jerk he is that he
has done it again this is so unfair I
have been nothing but good to him I've
been nothing but a great girlfriend and
have done everything that I could why
did he do this again to me and how did I
even get here and I kept on saying how
did I even get here how did I even get
here
and this weird voice kind of appeared
out of nowhere and she said girl it's
your fault you're the reason why you're
here in this situation you knew that he
was not good for you you knew that he
cheats on you you knew that he would lie
to you but you kept on going back over
and over again and at first I was like
no it's not my fault it's his fault and
I kept on fighting with myself and
eventually I knew was my fault to
continue on in this relationship so I
took responsibility at the age of 18 to
completely cut out that relationship and
move on with my life I actually ended at
that night and since then I haven't
and I apply the same philosophy in
everything that I do anytime I'm in a
situation that I feel like oh my god I
can't believe this happened to me again
I think to myself how much of it has to
do with me sometimes it's a hundred
percent my fault and sometimes it's two
percent but I'm the common denominator
it always comes back to me and as as
soon as I know that I know I could get
myself out and that is more empowering
than anything else so next time you're
in a situation that you're like oh my
god this is horrible
I cannot believe it this has happened to
me I'm such a victim in this and you
want to point and fingers on different
people and blame it on other people
blaming government regulations whatever
you like I have no control over that but
you do you have control over yourself if
you want things to work out your way and
you want success and happiness and joy
in your life you need to own your life
and the question of the day is what is
that terrible event that happened to you
that you need to take ownership for
right now write in the comments below
and I'll join in on the discussion and
have a special shout out for Danny
Collins Danny thank you so much for
picking up a copy of Evans book top ten
rules for success and taking that
awesome picture next to it
we really appreciate your support and I
hope you're enjoying the read and thank
you so much for watching we believe in
you and hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
and we'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of an espresso
[Music]
you
I was working once at an ice cream
parlor when I was about 15 years old my
first real job and on the second day I
was asked to scrape the gum off between
the Mexican tiles on the floor and I
said to the woman who owned the storms
called Magoo's ice cream parlor you
didn't hire me to scrape gum you hired
me to scoop ice cream and this this girl
this shoe store across the way that's
looking at me I don't want to see her me
scraping the gum and she said what are
you talking about I own this store I'll
do anything I want with you get down on
your knees and scrape that gum what I
said I'm not doing it
she said you're fired last job I ever
had I owe that woman everything I don't
like to work for people many of you in
here I hope and inherit that there's
nothing wrong with it if you want to
control your own destiny you work for
yourself that's how it works I'm trying
to inspire those of you are on the
tipping point take the chance you're
young go for it there's nothing better
than being able to wake up in the
morning 10 years or 20 years so now and
do what ever you like it's about freedom
that's what matters
I'm not saying being an employee's bad
but believe me being an entrepreneur is
better I'm a little bias if you're an
artist or a filmmaker or content creator
in general do you feel like you
shouldn't even go mainstream towards TV
or towards film or towards working with
a music label or should you focus on
creating it all yourself because it it
still helps a lot of people who don't
know how to do the online so yeah I mean
look there's there's no answer to that
question I think that it's one thing
that everybody but the successful people
fail to realize about any creative
industry is that there is absolutely no
defined path there isn't one so it's
about paving your own path and now for
me my path and then mainstream just
didn't work
and new media did work and for other
people it's entirely antithetical to
that where mainstream is exactly the
right place for them so there is no
formula that's that's right or wrong I'm
just much better versed in my own sure
the trajectory that I found myself and
that includes really running away from
the establishment into whatever the most
forward-thinking space is my whole
career has been in some way or another a
struggle against my own doubts all along
the way as much as people said gosh
you're so confident you know that
higher-performance guy and everything
else I'm like yeah but it doesn't mean I
don't struggle matter of fact I probably
put myself in situations where I must be
challenged and I must struggle more than
any normal sane person you know I'm
constantly pushing myself all the time
because I evaluate struggle is something
to be honored you know it used to be
strong goal a struggle was something
that was was truly honored by people
they thought that was something to build
character they thought that that was
something that was good and now we've
got to be such a convenient driven
society that's into ease and so much to
just I think an unbelievable level of
engage by M Sartre entitlement where
people don't think they have to earn it
and I'm always like wait you know if you
have a dream never forget if you knock
on the door of opportunity that it is
work who answers you know it takes a lot
of work to achieve your bigger dreams to
to become the best you you can be to
serve more to create more to contribute
that highest level and it's a long word
[Music]
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
up or so it would be like a little
beacon hey believe nation if you want to
know what the most important one word is
for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details